good good I imagine it helps that you
get along when it's just the two of you
on screen for so long might be
presumptuous maybe it did not it didn't
have to be that way
right could have been a nightmare right
it does help to make the journey of
making the film something really special
that you know unforgettable and
enjoyable experience I think we're both
decent enough actors to where if we
hated one another we could still make an
awesome movie could you though what the
process would have sucked
really yes when did you know you got
along it took me 10 seconds we stamped
each other's buds yeah right and then we
raced three circles race cuz you look
like you've been having a ton of fun
promoting the movie have you figured out
a way to get him back for the half face
selfie series that he's been putting
together I'm gonna wait a long amount of
time so that he'll think that I've
forgotten about it right and then I'll
strike right I'm planning something
tomorrow does is it is it open sort of
opens up your head to what would you do
if you were alone because we are never
alone now it's true ever yeah at what
point do you think you would run out of
things to do my first glass of wine yes
I would check my phone right no service
15 seconds later
panic attack no you know what then you
go into photos you take a quick glimpse
here like and I think exciting then you
start going into text messages
information looking at all those photos
right that keeps me busy for a little
bit then I'll go into notes notes yeah
one time I saw a note that just said no
I can't say it on TV if it is love you
two guys together even just based on the
trailer I don't know if you know there's
the online community and expectantly
that desperately wants you there it's
almost like a fanfiction thing where
they're putting you in their dream
fantasy into the next guardians I don't
know if you've seen
I don't know there's this that they've
beautiful like me is GRU it's a lady
Groot or she grew if I purchased you
grouped that's her tonight
lady Groot this one is a little a little
less I don't know if you've had a chance
to see I wish I had such subtle future
at what point do you realize that the
fans that you guys both have for the
things that you've done are just like
the most amazing things in the world
like when is that moment that you have
passion yeah we do a passenger
passionate passionate fans we do have
passionate fans you know I see it I see
you're not really on social media so
like I see it on that I see it some of
like you know when people tagged me on
Instagram and post things there's a lot
for me it was like when people started
doing fan artwork I mean I you know I
was I grew up drawing pictures out of
comic books and stuff I remember how
important that was to me as a kid so
when I saw people creating pictures you
know of star-lord or whatever you know I
that really meant something to me I've
seen I've had people come up that to me
that have my face tattooed on their body
and that's that's pretty crazy another
thing